and there is news on that front as it
relates to the national football league
and let's start with this jay glazer uh
reported last night that that there is
an active nfl player who has tested
positive for the coronavirus rams center
brian allen has coveted 19 and uh you
know that
look and it was inevitable right
uh that somebody connected to the nfl
was gonna get it there's just too many
people whether it's coaches whether it's
players whoever and it was just a matter
of time before a player tested positive
and uh you know if they find a way to
play these games until there's a vaccine
there will be players who test positive
and they're going to have to have a plan
in place for what they do with brian
allen it doesn't matter because
nothing's going on now you get a guy who
tests positive in september if they're
playing games you're going to have a
real issue
well yeah definitely i mean you know
that's why i think if we're going to do
that and even entertain the thought of
playing games there has to be like
weekly testing for the whole
organization to make that go forward you
know this yeah big sacrifices will have
to be made by players too you know and
again you know uh to brian allen you
know i hope you stay safe and healthy
and everything goes out the right way i
also want brian allen to kind of keep us
informed with how he's feeling and i
would like to hear the symptoms we've
yet to really hear an nfl football
player talk about it uh and you know i
would like to hear you know his thoughts
on and and his feelings on what it is
done to him you know emotionally
physically and everything like that just
to get a better gauge of how it is
affecting nfl football players so yeah
it's crazy but you're i mean to me it's
shocking that this is really the first
one what is it over 1200 players in the
nfl at this time right now uh to to have
our first one this late in the process
is actually a little surprising to me
actually with rosters up to 90 right now
2800 is the maximum although there are
yeah spots for the players who are going
to be drafted and signed next week when
the draft gets rolling it's the draft
the seven rounds and then that land rush
for undrafted free agents but when the
dust settles there will be 2 800 plus
nfl players throughout the country and i
think brian allen is just the first of
many again for now it doesn't matter it
matters though if we have positive tests
and guys who are battling covet 19 when
we get into football season because once
it gets into a locker room it is going
to spread like wildfire
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports